[Music]
it's the midnight calls because the cows
got out
it's a milk or didn't show up so my dad
milked the other night
it's feeding the cows every day it's
planting it's harvesting it's
24 7. dairy industry if you don't love
it if you don't have a passion for it
you wouldn't stay in business you have
to be committed you have to be
passionate you have to sacrifice a lot
of time and if you don't have those
three then you farming's really just not
for you we just have a busy life and
it's what we love
we've been in the dairy business for 92
years um here we've been uh for eight
years in tennessee we were prior to that
we were in california
and uh left there because of a high cost
of doing business i really
enjoy seeing a well-bred cow that's put
together nicely that walks fluidly and
has a beautiful letter and then produces
lots of milk
dairy is just something i've always
liked
unfortunately the clock doesn't go back
for me it only goes forward right and
i'm really happy that she's here
and uh she is
a big big asset to our farm she's a
farmer she's a hard worker and she's
great singer-songwriter as well so we're
glad to have her here tonight y'all miss
stephanie nash everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you know my dad just knows he
knew something was coming with the dairy
industry in california he knew if we
didn't get out now we probably would end
up selling out like a lot of his friends
in california are now the biggest thing
with california is regulations i mean
they regulate us on every step we make
water rights
milk prices feed prices
regulations on climate change we're
constantly looked at
constantly manipulated and
told what to do and how to farm and
farmers especially my dad's age and
older they don't want to be told how to
farm they've done it their whole life
and they're being told by people that
have never farmed once in their life
yeah they weren't worried about farmers
there
no
being in tennessee
is better we still have to fight for
fair prices again we still have to fight
for people to buy milk in the stores and
ice cream in the stores buy local if you
have to
drive 10 extra miles you're helping a
family business and i do believe in
small businesses over corporate america
any day
the last farm bill the dairy policy was
put together without a lot of input from
farmers
and so the effect of it is they changed
our pricing mechanism
and what that has done is taken nearly a
billion dollars out of the dairy
industry out of the farming segment out
of my segment and moved it to processors
and other people in in the industry
before it gets to the grocery store
that has been very difficult for a lot
of people and and myself included
we have government programs that have
been put in place the last
couple of years to help with coven
while we use them
we don't like them i just want to i want
a fair price that represents the work
that we do
and the nutritional product that we make
we have a great product
why is the government got to support us
because we can't make it on our own
that's that's the fundamental issue here
we opened up a cheese plant uh you know
to help with costs because feed costs
are through the roof
and we really depend on a fair price for
feed costs to feed our animals
you look at big seed companies you look
at the ethanol plants you look at all
these
big investors again going back to
politicians what are they investing in
why are they putting the infrastructure
bill and all this funding into certain
areas because they're going to make more
money the farmer is going to be dead and
the family farms are going to be
gone and they're going to continue to
get richer off of stuff like plant-based
and climate change it's just a big old
hoax i think my generation is probably
one of the last that wants to take on
the struggle and the hardships of
farming public perception is huge in
opinions and media and so
it's just really hard to
bring up a next generation that doesn't
have somebody to mentor them into
agriculture and i hope by advocating and
having the store and the cheese that we
can financially stay afloat that's what
everybody prays for we pray for rain we
pray for fair prices we pray for
regulations that are not going to kill
off our industry so looking to the
future we really do need some forces
to help us
keep our next generation going in our
food supply for the american people
we are
uh
you know in a place
that we could go either way
and uh
i've been there many times before
so
we'll just have to see what the next few
months bring